[Música]
olá gente eu nunca vou esquecer de um
dos meus primeiros e principais clientes
que chamava rogério rogério ele passou
quase a vida toda dele está a construir
o primeiro milhão dele e depois disso
não parou por aí ele já sede de grana de
dinheiro ele queria ficar mais rico e
não parou aí
ele chegou em 2º 3º 4º 5º e aí ele foi
ficando cada vez mais rico
só que o rogério quando ele conseguiu
finalmente atingir o sucesso financeiro
dele ele foi abatido por uma doença
muito grave
bateu o câncer na porta da casa dele ele
é tocada centavo que ele demorou a vida
toda pra construir com essa doença
eu comecei a me questionar foi pouco do
que valeu tudo isso do que valeu tudo
que ele fez
será que esse cara tivesse tido um pouco
mais de equilíbrio na vida e um pouco
mais de educação financeira e não teria
vindo um pouco melhor se um pouquinho
mais feliz será que a família dele não
teria sido um pouquinho mais feliz
e disso eu tinha o seguinte ele
trabalhou a vida toda pelo dinheiro mas
quem tem que trabalhar pra quem né a
gente trabalha pelo dinheiro ou será que
o dinheiro tem que trabalhar pra gente
então esse tipo de questão começou a
mexer muito comigo e rogério foi a
pessoa que foi muito responsável pelo
que eu faço hoje
e conforme o tempo foi passando e eu
comecei a me questionar e eu cheguei à
conclusão que a gente tem três concelhos
quente vive recebendo e eu queria saber
se você já receberam algum desses três
primeiro em vista na poupança porque ela
é mais seguro
alguém já ouviu cumprir o seu próprio
imóvel porque o imóvel é mais seguro e
terceiro tem o seu próprio carro porque
ele é seu e você também fica mais seguro
então esses três concelhos
eles também não se aplica muito bem mais
um dia de hoje mas porque a gente recebe
esses três conselhos sempre
porque na vida dos nossos pais é um
conceito muito importante não estava tão
presente que é o conceito de educação
financeira
mas a culpa não é deles não a culpa é
simplesmente do contexto que a gente
vive porque a gente era guiado pelo medo
e não pela educação
se você parar pra pensar estava em um
momento que a gente precisava no mercado
fazem estoque porque o preço subir no
outro dia a gente tinha medo de que
confisca se o nosso dinheiro ele
colocava ele toda na polpa é debaixo do
colchão e não investir nosso dinheiro né
então como a gente não pensava no longo
prazo porque a gente tinha medo que eles
pensavam no curto prazo não se planejava
não tinha educação financeira e por isso
é tão difícil a gente passar alguns
conceitos da forma correta para frente e
já que a gente está falando desse tipo
de conceito eu acho que antigamente
talvez eles até se aplicassem porque se
você for para pensar quando a economia
estava meio estranha começaram a surgir
alguns sinais positivos a poupança por
exemplo já chegou a render mais do que
mil por cento no ano
não sei se vocês sabem disso alguém se
arrisca a dizer quanto à poupança rende
mais ou menos hoje 587 de mais ou menos
isso 17 por cento hoje ao ano
mas eu fiz umas contas e se a gente
tivesse aplicado 100 mil reais
há três anos atrás sabe quanto a gente
teria de lucro na poupança
noventa e oito reais
você pode pensar não pára aí mas entre
7% e 7% de 100 mil das sete mil reais
como que rende 98 reais em três anos eu
te digo que a gente considera a inflação
porque a inflação foi tão alta quanto o
rendimento da poupança ea gente pergunta
de novo
será que dá pra enriquecer investir na
poupança
será que a gente deixe nosso dinheiro na
poupança a gente está trabalhando pelo
dinheiro o dinheiro está trabalhando por
nós e por isso eu acho que esse é um
mito que a gente tem que tirar o segundo
mito
o mito investimento mobiliário né em
alguns casos faz sentido comprar o seu
próprio imóvel mas na maioria deles não
porque se você pegasse o mesmo dinheiro
você poderia utilizar para comprar um
imóvel mas você colocar esse dinheiro em
uma aplicação financeira
você teria mais dinheiro e rendimento
você teria mais liquidez
você poderia movimentar o seu dia de uma
forma mais fácil mas claro lá atrás o
investimento imobiliário é muito
rentável porque nos últimos 50 anos o
brasil se formou basicamente então como
há 50 anos são paulo era quase uma
floresta em muitos lugares
qualquer investimento mobiliário subia
hoje já não é mais bem assim
a gente tem muitos anos em que o
investimento imobiliário é até
rendimento negativo então por causa de
todas essas questões
faz sentido eu me apresentar um
pouquinho pra poder chegar no ponto que
faz sentido é ea reflexão que eu quero
trazer para vocês hoje eu sou tiago
negro eu tenho mais ou menos sete anos
no mercado financeiro e os meus pais
eles construíram uma poupança para mim
né
e eles passaram quase que 17 anos
juntando dinheiro pra mim todo mês e lá
colocar um pouquinho outro mês ela
colocar mais um pouquinho e no final né
quando eu atingi meus quase 18 anos
eu pude ter acesso a esse dinheiro e
quando tive acesso a esse dinheiro
aconteceu uma coisa muito curiosa
meus pais demoraram 17 anos para juntar
esse dinheiro eu demorei uma semana pra
perder ele todo eu peguei esse dinheiro
eu quebrei assim foi a primeira vez que
eu quebrei
eu peguei isso tudo eu coloquei na bolsa
eu tinha um grande sonho de se aplicar a
globo wallstreet dos filmes mercado
financeiro ficar comprando e vendendo
ação o tempo todo e eu realmente tentei
fazer isso por uma semana eu perdi tudo
que eu tinha
e daqui me motivou muito a estudar e aí
eu não me conformei como eu pude perder
tudo isso eu comecei a tirar várias
certificações no mercado financeiro e
quando eu fiz isso eu tinha certeza que
eu queria trabalhar no mercado
financeiro
então eu pensei eu quero trabalhar em
banco de investimento
e aí eu comecei a fazer um roadshow de
entrevistas em bancos de investimentos e
os entraves em todos aqueles bancos que
vocês já ouviram falar nos filmes em
jornais morgan stanley e merrill lynch
credit suisse e goldman sacks todos
esses mas nenhum me abriu as portas
eu cheguei na entrevista final de muitos
deles
mas não passa nenhum então não conseguir
fazer o que eu queria mas eu tinha um
sonho e trabalho mercado financeiro que
eu fiz eu montei meu próprio negócio
há mais ou menos seis anos atrás quase
sete anos
o meu negócio era um negócio de
assessoria de investimentos
eu ajudava as pessoas investirem mas
imagina se eu sou novo hoje como que era
quase sete anos atrás era difícil passar
muita credibilidade né
e foi difícil foi trabalhoso eu fiquei
muito tempo sem ganhar dinheiro mas eu
consegui construir um negócio então
quase seis anos depois eu montei o 10º
maior escritório de assessoria de
investimentos do país e com isso eu
tinha mais de 5 mil clientes
eu tinha mais de 30 pessoas na minha
equipe eu estava ganhando dinheiro e
está a investir em novos projetos e um
desses projetos é um projeto digital
porque eu queria atingir mais pessoas eu
queria captar mais clientes a empresa
então entre na internet ontem um canal
no youtube
montei um site blog facebook tudo isso
né em nome desse projeto era o primo
rico e tudo estava dando muito certo na
vida eu estava acendendo eu estava
crescendo trazendo dinheiro
só que lembra do rogério hoje era um
cliente muito importante pra mim o que
aconteceu com ele foi que quando estava
tudo dando certo
eu recebo a notícia rogério estava em
uma fase terminal
isso daqui me deixou muito abalado
a gente sabia que era questão de tempo e
eu me aproximo me tanto do rogério que
eu sabia segredos que a família dele não
sabia eu e me deixou orientações para
ajudar a família dele caso acontecesse
alguma coisa com ele eu saber de
segredos
isso daqui me deixou muito abalado e
paralelamente eu recebi uma oferta de
venda pela empresa
eu pensei eu preciso atingir mais gente
eu preciso educar financeiramente mais
pessoas
só que hoje eu só falo com 5 mil
clientes
eu preciso atingir o brasil todo a gente
tem mais de 200 milhões de pessoas
e aí eu tomei a decisão eu decidir nessa
hora eu entendi que o meu propósito era
educar financeiramente todo o brasil e
eu vendi a minha empresa
eu foquei no meu projeto digital e
quando foi que no prédio digital eu
comecei a produzir muito conteúdo do
youtube principalmente hoje eu falo com
mais de 1 milhão de pessoas por mês na
internet no meu canal
isso daqui começou a fazer muito sentido
para mim então eu queria fazer aqui uma
brincadeira com vocês e eu preciso que
vocês prestem muita atenção em mim muita
muita atenção mesmo em mim agora faço
exatamente o que eu falar por favor
todo mundo levanta a mão direita beleza
presta muita atenção no que eu vou dizer
que faz exatamente o que eu fizer por
favor levantem o seu dedo indicador
olha o dedo que vocês levantaram a
maioria de vocês porque vocês levantar o
dedão e não indicador que eu pedi
perceberam como exemplo é muito forte
exemplo ele é mais forte mais importante
do que a gente fala o que a gente faz é
responsável por transformações gigantes
e quando percebi isso entende que o meu
propósito era ajudar a transformar o
brasil financeiramente através do
exemplo e agora que você entender um
pouco mais de como a educação financeira
poderia ter transformado a vida do
rogério a vida de várias pessoas que
vocês entenderam como exemplo é poderoso
eu gostaria que vocês agora me ajudassem
e cientistas responsáveis por me ajudar
me ajudará a disseminar esse tipo de
informação que é tão importante hoje no
brasil e que auxiliassem atingir o meu
propósito
obrigado
[Aplausos]